it wasn't the discovering of my why that
set me on the path it was the
discovering of my why and then wanting
desperately to share with my friends CU
I love my friends and I want them to
have what I found and they started
making Crazy Life Changes and making
these huge decisions with total
confidence and they would invite me to
their homes to share it with their
friends and I would literally stand in
someone's living room talking about this
thing called the Y and that's what
ignite ignited the spark that I realized
that I I had something to give um um and
you discover you discover service I mean
this is what a life of service means
which is um you know the the reason you
know people keep talking about or we're
told you have a gift you know well the
very definition of a gift is it's
supposed to be given and I think that if
you have a gift and you're not sharing
it I think you're just selfish